bien gibeau bonjour
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
le disais c'est dans la province
italienne du tyrol du sud qu'on voit ces
écoles clandestines secret par des
familles qui sont opposés aux
restrictions sanitaires quelle est
l'ampleur du phénomène
le phénomène reste quand même
extrêmement marginale par rapport à ce
qui pourrait être l'école normale bien
entendu on parle de 600 700 élèves mais
entendu par rapport à la population
italienne qui est de plus de 50 millions
d'habitants c'est très relatif même la
région la toscane par exemple à peu près
1200 1300 élèves qui sont hors du
système on va dire classique donc ça
reste quand même très marginale mais ce
qui est évident dans les statistiques
italienne actuellement c'est que depuis
deux ans depuis on va dire la crise dako
vide il ya une forte augmentation par
exemple en toscane justement est passé
de 300 à 1300 étudiants sortis du
système et par rapport à la population
du sud tyrol qu'une petite population 6
700 étudiants et élèves qui sont sortis
du système sol devient le plus important
qu'avant on va dire que la croissance
est très forte accueil et pourquoi est
ce que le nord de l'italie est pourquoi
dans le nord il ya plus de personnes qui
sont anti vaccins qu'ailleurs
il ya très certainement un facteur
vraiment culturelles et même
traditionnel où par tradition vraiment
on a toujours des mouvements assez fort
anti vaccins le pire on avait ce
mouvement le sud-tyrol celle un très
fort le mouvement antivaccinal lien le
plus fort est à trieste donc au nord-est
il ya ces mouvements régulièrement et
les facteurs historiques bien sûr
puisque la le sud-tyrol est une région
qui est vraiment à cheval entre l'italie
et l'autriche culturellement
germanophone et germanique mais
également italien il ya toujours un peu
comment dire une légère opposition
constant parce qu'il pourrait être
l'autorité de rome parce que cette
région du sud tyrol et justement un peu
à cheval on avait vu il ya quelques
années l'autriche qui avait proposé des
passeports à cette population pour que
les faire devenir autrichien est
toujours un peu cette vallée qui n'a pas
vraiment choisi son bay on va dire et ce
parti souverainiste est ce que
finalement c'est aussi une action
politique la création de ces écoles
clandestines
oui bien sûr il ya toujours un peu de sa
gestion de politiques autour parce que
le sud-tyrol comme le val d'aoste où les
imageurs la sardaigne et la sicile font
parti des régions à statut spécial
c'est à dire que ce sont des régions de
semi autonomie en italie pouvoir le
quasi autonomie parfois avec un
parlement et un gouvernement une langue
locale tout quasiment toutes ces régions
donc oui bien sûr qu'il y ait un aspect
un peu de défi par rapport au pays sans
aucun doute pour renforcer toujours
cette idée après ces mouvements
indépendantistes sont ceux généralement
on va dire à ses limites et il essaie de
jouer la carte justement du statut
spécial qui permet de choisir les lois
sur le territoire tout en restant en
italie et en restant dans le système
italie quelles sont les contraintes qui
pèsent justement sur sur les écoliers
qui font que des familles décident de
sortir leurs enfants du système
classique
il ya plusieurs contraintes qui ont très
certainement portait justement ces
familles a décidé cela une augmentation
des vaccins obligatoires depuis 2000 19
en italie il y avait quatre vaccin
obligatoire depuis 2010 9 et la loi de
la ministre lorenzin il y en a 10 donc
très certainement des familles qui ne
veulent pas justement vacciner leurs
enfants la loi italienne le permet 1 il
est tout à fait possible de laisser son
enfant hors du système jusqu'à jusqu'au
lycée injuste l'université ne peut pas
être fait à la maison et tout le reste
de la scolarité est autorisée donc il y
ait beaucoup de familles qui par rapport
à une opposition anti vaccins par
rapport à d'autres raisons très
certainement certaines tout simplement
parce que durant le coc vide ils se sont
rendus compte qu'ils avaient
travailler à la maison décide de sortir
les élèves du système scolaire italien
c'est la loi ils sont autorisés à le
faire et comment réagissent les pouvoirs
publics justement est-ce qu'ils ont les
moyens d'intervenir
techniquement la loi et de le côté des
familles donc il n'y a pas vraiment
quelque chose à faire si les familles
veulent s'organiser pour faire justement
des cours à la maison rien ne les
empêche de le faire
l'inde estime voilà on parle de tout à
fait à rien ce problème des cols blancs
destine c'est le problème qui a lui
aussi pendant la colline où justement
les élèves devaient suivre les cours en
ligne à la maison il y avait beaucoup de
familles en italie qui se retrouvé ivre
europe et les élèves et sabine entendu
c'est justement très très
contre-productif on va dire que le
problème c'est le maillage c'est réussir
aussi à contrôler on est dans des micros
écoles clandestines justement c'est très
difficile pour l'état de réussir à
contrôler cette situation ce qui est sûr
c'est qu'on va dire que débute cette
semaine même dans la pluie la semaine
dernière où la rentrée on se débat s'est
rouvert d'un point de vue de l'état
c'est à dire qu'il ya une réflexion des
autorités italiennes pour re voir quelle
serait la solution pour pouvoir mieux
contrôler justement les élèves qui ne
sont plus dans le système dans le
système scolaire il ya plusieurs idées
déjà plus de contrôle par rapport au
niveau scolaire de ses élèves peut-être
la fin de l'année par exemple pour les
réintégrer après dans le système est ce
que le les restrictions qui sont imposés
en italie comme partout en europe 1 on a
vu les manifestations à trieste contre
contre le passé ni terre est ce que ces
restrictions font émerger justement ces
mouvements souverainistes comme c'est le
cas notamment dans le nord de l'italie
il ya beaucoup de facteurs c'est bien
sûr un le mouvement anti valls en italie
n'est pas que le mouvement dit valls on
a vu qu'il y avait d'autres mouvements
qui s'était intégré un peu anti anti
tout finalement ou en tout cas
souverainiste
principalement rome bien entendu à la
capitale n'a vu plusieurs mouvements
anti-vaccins plusieurs manifestations
très importantes qui réunit
l'intégration d'autres franges qui
n'était pas du tout antidote mais qui
était beaucoup plus politisé politiser à
l'extrême droite donc il ya aussi ce
facteur aujourd'hui de savoir quelle va
être la ligne directrice c'est aussi on
va dire directement un conflit des
personnes qui sont dans les mouvements
anti vaccin parce qu'ils se retrouvent
dans un mouvement parfois
mélangé avec d'autres revendications qui
n'ont pas toujours un rapport direct
donc il va y avoir forcément aussi là
peut-être une coalition total à la fin
peut-être une séparation justement la
ville de milan extrêmement touché par
exemple ça fait des semaines et des
semaines que certaines rues de la ville
sont bloquées tous les samedis par les
mouvements tivat mais pas uniquement
justement et donc il y aura très
certainement une réflexion à voir aussi
pour les manifestants merci beaucoup
fabien gilot je le rappelle vous êtes
enseignant à l'université de turin